Speaker 1: We have a really interesting
political situation that surfaced in the last
24 to 48 hours, a poll came out from the
perennially unreliable Rasmussen Reports,
which says that if the 20 24 election were held
today and Donald Trump were the Republican nominee
and Joe Biden were the Democratic nominee,
Donald Trump would defeat Biden by 10 points,
51 to 41. Now, what is interesting about this,
other than, you know, it's three years out and a
poll right now is sort of meaningless. There
are two things that are very interesting.
One is I don't actually disagree with the
general conclusion. And that conclusion
is that Donald Trump might easily win in 2024
against Joe Biden. I've actually said before,
when I think about 20, 24 big picture, I don't
really see Joe Biden at age 81 days short of his
80 second birthday in November of twenty twenty
four, defeating Donald Trump after four years
of Trump talking about how terrible Joe
Biden is, I see it as a big uphill battle.
If Biden says no thanks, I'm not running for
reelection. But Kamala Harris is the nominee as of
right now. Kamala Harris, his approval rating is
not good. And I don't see Kamala defeating Donald
Trump in a general election either. And that's why
I've been saying the best scenario is Donald Trump
not running in twenty, twenty four. But that
doesn't change that. This poll, a Rasmussen poll
three years out, is really not worth much at
all. But all the normal stuff starts happening
when the poll comes out. The Washington
Examiner starts writing headlines about
the poll. Trump over Biden by 10 points, Harris
by 13. Trump then publishes a reference on his
website to the poll and a link to this very same
Washington Examiner article. And the ecosystem
starts to repeat itself and build on itself.
So this is a sort of weird situation because
I think Trump could absolutely win in 2024,
but without knowing what happens in 2022
and what the next, you know, at least 18
months of the Joe Biden presidency look like,
it is very hard to say anything substantive about
the specifics of Trump vs. Biden in twenty 24
hour Republican voters ignorant enough to elect
Donald Trump again. Absolutely. Of course they
are. Which is why it would be better for Donald
Trump not to run. And whatever that reason is
Trump becoming convinced that he can't win.
When I was on the Michael Cohen podcast a
few weeks ago or maybe six weeks ago,
something like that, Michael Cohen said,
I don't think Trump will run because he can't
handle another disappointment. He can't handle
another hit to his ego. He just he just can't
handle it. And so he doesn't want the chance
of losing again and he's not going to run. But
at the same time, Trump is a major narcissist,
and it takes a lot for Trump to think he can't
win. Trump tends to think he can win. He tends
to think of himself as invincible. And that, to
me, signals that he very well may run unless it's
abundantly clear that he has no shot. It would
be better for Trump not to run because there's
no question that the American public, as a result
of its composition, with so many low information,
radicalized Republicans would vote for Trump
again, at least plausibly. The message here
is that the exact coalition that brought
Biden his victory in 2020, which came down to
not that many votes in a few states,
remember massive popular vote victory,
bigger margin than Trump when it came
to electoral, not in electoral votes,
but the combined margin in the states that made a
difference. It was a few hundred thousand rather
than just the 77000 votes in three states that
pushed Trump over 270. But Biden's coalition was
very precarious. A slight departure from it could
have seen Donald Trump reelected. And that's not
a threat that should be understated. So do
we care about Rasmussen three years out? No,
not specifically. The polling is bogus, but the
message that Trump could definitely win in 2024
is an accurate message, and that's the
one that we should be paying attention to.